some quick thinking fast-food workers  are being credited with saving a woman  in Northern California sheriff's  deputies in San Joaquin County say a man  followed the woman inside this  McDonald's and ordered her to leave with  him employees say the woman was already  acting frantic before the man came in  there suspicions were confirmed when the  woman pulled up to the drive-through and  mouthed the words helped me to one of  the workers the employees use their  emergency training and held up the  drive-thru line until police could  arrive the woman told police the man had  abused her in the past and threatened to  kill her the man was arrested and  charged with making criminal threats and  illegally possessing a gun holy Smokies  American she's great thinking yeah and  apparently the gun was in the car  you